bonjour café politique onzième numéro
les élus qui se succèdent ici au bistrot
du théâtre à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
invité aujourd'hui guimalandin bonjour
mère socialiste de la ville
de la ville de Trappes on va revenir au
cours de la prochaine demi-heure comme
avec les autres élus qui vous ont
précédé sur votre parcours sur les
grands dossiers qui vous occupent
également mais forcément on va débuter
par votre réaction à l'actualité
dramatique de ces derniers jours
d'actualité qui a touché votre commune
la mort de Moussa 14 ans victime d'une
rafale de balle au pied de son immeuble
une blessure notamment son ami qui est à
côté de 17 ans blessé à la jambe des
événements dramatiques au-delà de
l'émotion et de la colère est-ce qu'il y
a une inquiétude particulière sur cette
commune de Trappes
alors pour être très prudent au delà de
la douleur etc pour l'instant on ne peut
pas se prononcer je ne veux pas me
prononcer sur Oui c'est une histoire
entre la grande Camus ou c'est autre
chose tant qu'on n'a pas le résultat de
l'enquête disant qui a assassiné Moussa
qui a blessé kaouter et et pourquoi
alors le travail en train de se faire
par les services spécialisés voilà j'ai
reçu hier après-midi après avoir vu
accompagné etc
une trentaine de de famille de maman en
particulier du square Camus pour pour
leur demande à leur initiative mais en
même temps ils m'ont demandé vendredi je
les ai reçu hier pour voir comment
comment on fait leur idée et de d'avoir
des réunions de dialogue avec un certain
nombre de jeunes et donc c'est avec le
club de prévention c'est avec le service
jeunesse il y a les parents qui ont une
responsabilité
je mets de côté les services spéciaux
qui travaillent mais ça c'est pas c'est
à faire de l'État c'est dire
pour
retrouver
ou trouver des moyens de dialogue des
moyens d'échange moyen de compréhension
et puis ne pas ne pas amplifier
bon ce qui est la haine et l'assassinat
hein
oui oui il y a un échec
sociétal je veux dire les politiques ont
leur responsabilités on sait quelque
chose mais la société aussi
l'obésité 12 exemples
je ne suis pas dit prophète ni rien et
voilà la plus grosse erreur qu'on a
faite c'est de supprimer le service
national je parle pas service militaire
pour se battre etc je parle du service
national ou on se lève le
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
qui qui formait
et faisait passer les diplômes et tout
à des garçons et à des filles c'est un
pensionnat plutôt que d'aller en prison
ils allaient ils allaient là ils
apprenaient un métier ils apprenaient
des choses etc on l'a fermé moi je vous
dirai pas parce que je veux pas entrer
dans des trucs politiciens je sais je
sais qui était le décideur à l'époque on
l'a fermé comme d'autres et puis c'est
resté comme ça et trois ans après
c'était tout abîmé tout démoli avec des
des machines outils neuves etc donc je
veux pas si c'est là dessus mais il faut
bien qu'il y a un moment de rencontre
entre
je veux dire les institutions
républicaines ma place par rapport aux
autres etc et puis il faut aussi penser
que la prison mais pour 90% des cas je
parle de de jeunes gens n'est pas la
bonne réponse on va parler de vous à
présent de votre parcours alors je
reprends mes notes tout de même pour ne
rien oublier engagement dans les années
70 c'était au sein du CRS le Centre
d'études de recherche et d'éducation
socialiste un mouvement qui a participé
à la fondation du Parti socialiste et
puis ensuite qui deviendra lui-même un
parti le Mouvement des citoyens de
Jean-Pierre Chevènement Jean-Pierre
Chevènement je vais faire un petit
raccourci que vous avez soutenu en 2002
d'ailleurs pendant la campagne
présidentielle le résultat 21 avril 2002
on s'en souvient le troisième homme
entre Jospin et Chirac ce n'est pas
Chevènement c'est Le Pen qui arrive
également au second tour vous l'avez
regretté ce soutien Jean-Pierre
Chevènement dont
non j'ai pas le parc d'été et je le
regrette pas parce qu'il y avait une
campagne politique c'est et comment dire
ou bien c'est un moment de vérité
un moment d'hérité ça a toujours des
risques je demande pas qu'on me pardonne
ça c'est
un moment un moment politique
c'est un moment de donc je répète de
vérité et moi j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé non pas seulement parce que
il y avait une histoire fraternelle
entre Jean-Pierre et moi depuis depuis
65 donc c'est pas c'est pas d'hier mais
parce que il y avait des choses à dire
et je pense que pendant cette campagne
je vais demander des choses qu'on
devrait peut-être lire et et et
réécouter pas besoin de de toujours
d'accord comme ça et puis
est apparu à ce moment-là une vraie une
réalité qui qui continue qui pour moi
est est vraiment
insupportable pour mes convictions mais
pour mes convictions pas seulement
politique mais convictions humanistes
c'est c'est le parcours du du Front
national que je dis souvent il change de
langage mais le fond est le même
et
qui est bon chargé chargé historiquement
de choses insupportables alors on n'est
pas forcément
héritier en photocopie de ce qui s'est
passé avant mais
c'est pas avec de l'exclusion c'est pas
avec de la haine c'est pas avec du
mensonge qu'on redonnera un peu de un
peu d'humanisme mais aussi de qualité et
de vie quotidienne à la population
française
je dis population française qui
incorpore
et toutes les origines et attrapes on
est on moi je suis heureux de ça de
cette diversité de la gentillesse des
des gens de l'effort qui font pour
passer d'une tradition je veux dire à la
nôtre qui a ses qualités mais qui a
aussi ses défauts et donc c'est ce
mouvement humaniste que
je trouve on devrait mettre en avant et
qui est
compromis par
la montée du Front national qui sert
d'exutoire à mécontentement c'est un peu
comme ça
qu'est-ce qui explique vos convictions
de gauche aussi votre engagement alors
au sein du Parti socialiste au côté de
Jean-Pierre chevène donc elle a été
l'élément déclencheur il y a toujours un
élément déclencheur dans un parcours
politique un jour oui c'est
un peu sembler étrange maintenant quoi
d'abord c'est une éducation moi j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser j'allais dire
dans la politique tout à fait tout à
fait jaune un peu en tradition familiale
quoi un père syndicaliste enfin bref
c'est ça compte ça compte l'éducation et
puis ce qui pour moi a été a été
vraiment le le choc en disant je peux
pas rester comme ça et je dois m'engager
je dois dire des choses faire des choses
et puis me tromper parfois
c'est la guerre d'Algérie moi j'ai passé
30 mois là-bas dans dans des conditions
parfois
avec ça mais dans des conditions parfois
difficiles mais quand quand on a 20 ans
et qu'on vit ça
on revient pas pareil que quand on est
parti votre parcours dit local et lui
sur le terrain conseiller municipal de
Fargis ça c'était de 7783 en parallèle
du poste de conseiller général sur sur
Rambouillet maire adjoint ensuite à
Élancourt de 83 à 95 95 pardon vous avez
donc changé de secteur avant ensuite
l'élection de la droite elle en cours là
vous êtes partis
vous êtes parti juste avant avant 95 et
puis attrape ensuite au début pour les
pour les amis 2001 vous avez commencé à
prendre la tête de cette commune vous
avez un petit peu comme ça tournait
autour de différentes communes pourquoi
ce parcours un petit peu de Rambouillet
à Élancourt attrapes c'est un parcours
qui est qui est
motivé par des réponses à des demandes
quand et c'est comme ça
en village dans lequel je rentre dormir
depuis 40 ans
voilà et ayant des activités
professionnelles et puis des activités
politiques beaucoup plus périphériques
bon et et il se fait que à un moment
donné les la section socialiste des
locaux qui avaient regardé c'était un
peu juste c'était monsieur ne veut qui
était candidat pour pour la droite une
droite très très centriste quoi voilà à
l'époque et puis il a dit oui ça risque
pas passé qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va
demander aux députés de venir c'est un
peu paraître je le dis en souriant parce
que c'est comme c'est passé donc ils
m'ont invité une réunion section et puis
moi je dis bon si il s'agit quand même
dans l'agglomération de donner un coup
de main voilà je suis rentré en cours
mais pas comme mère comme comme adjoint
voilà ça avec une promesse absolue mais
certains ont parlé d'opportunisme aussi
on a dit voilà vous allez sur secteur là
parce que c'est plus facile c'est plus
possible donc vous partez à Trappes
non non c'est pas du tout comme ça que
ça français et j'ai fait donc de mandats
à Élancourt et puis le même le même
scénario bon et en cours il y avait du
monde il y a pas besoin de moi quoi pour
être clair pour et et les copains de
Trappes m'ont dit voilà nous on est un
peu un peu en désert
au manque de bras si je puis dire est-ce
que tu tu veux venir j'ai réfléchi
vraiment longtemps parce que c'est pas
pareil et donc faut être comme fonction
comme mission comme Charles comme comme
façon façon d'être et de concevoir la
politique et maintenant je regrette pas
parce que j'ai découvert les choses
extraordinaires pour moi formidable pour
moi je le dis comme ça ça peut paraître
enfantin mais quand quand je vais au
marché quand je vais dans un quartier ou
quoi
vraiment tout le monde tout le monde dit
bonjour Voilà même s'il y a des accords
il y a des accords quoi mais tout dit
bonjour avec une
gentillesse une forme d'amitié mais vous
êtes si vous avez été à député on l'a
mentionné brièvement aussi mais poste de
secrétaire d'État de ministre ça par
contre ça ne figure pas dans votre CV
est-ce que c'est un regret alors comment
vous l'expliquez parce que il y a des
choses qui se disent aussi il y avait
des hommes forts sur le département des
Yvelines et quelques années vous ont
faisiez partie avec également Michel
Rocard et vous n'avez pas forcément
d'affinité avec lui et c'est que moi
c'est lui qui n'avait pas d'affinité
avec nous
parce que et ça venait pas de lui alors
cette tension entre vous deux une
politique politicienne mais c'est ce qui
explique en tout cas qu'après vous
n'ayez pas
le ministre j'étais le responsable du
CRS au Parti socialiste dans le
département enfin avec d'autres mais il
veut dire voilà et puis et puis Michel
et surtout des amis à lui était
responsables du courant Rocard quoi
voilà
on a une gauche à gauche et une gauche
plus à droite c'est un petit peu ça
et voilà et puis on on
s'entendait pas bien et donc je peux le
raconter j'ai été une fois une fois
proposé
ministre du Logement et
en 48 heures c'était réglé c'était non
parce que parce que voilà Monsieur
malandrin il est un peu têtu il dit des
choses qu'il faut pas dire
et peut-être que
c'est Louis Besson qui a été nommé
ministre et
pour moi non non
a fait un boulot formidable et moi j'ai
travaillé avec lui sur plusieurs lois
qui durent encore aujourd'hui voilà
guimalandin le maire de Trappes qui est
l'invité de ce café politique on fait
une courte pause et ensuite on va parler
des principaux dossiers quelques-uns des
principaux dossiers de votre commune
seconde partie du café politique les
élus qui évoquent aussi les dossiers
importants qui concernent leur commune
Guy Malandain pour débuter cette
séquence c'est la tradition à
micro-trottoir nous sommes allés voir à
vos administrer leur demander ce qu'il
pensait tout simplement de leur commune
ce qu'il pensait trappe écouter
plus d'espace de jeux pour les jeunes la
violence déjà
ça changera jamais et ce qui me plaît
c'est trappes quoi moi je me trouve bien
trap bon manque un peu de magasin
tout va bien
on a tout ce qu'il faut c'est bien servi
là on a les bus on a le train on a tout
ce qu'il faut aussi il y a qu'une chose
à dire maintenant on aime bien notre
ville malgré qu'il y a des problèmes et
on aime bien notre ville
on a perdu un petit il y a pas longtemps
et voilà c'est tout moi ça fait qu'un an
que je suis là donc mais j'y suis bien
et j'ai choisi mon quartier un petit peu
plus d'activités au niveau du commerce
ça va un peu plus de choix on y est très
bien il y a pas de souci on voit qu'il y
a beaucoup d'efforts de faits pour la
sécurité l'environnement les
aménagements donc on y vit très bien il
y a pas de souci
les gens sont globalement contents c'est
une belle ville on y est bien elle est
bien desservie même si on a entendu tout
de même une personne dire la violence ça
le changera jamais un peu de résignation
aussi bon
l'essentiels
c'est l'attachement de mes concitoyens à
la ville y compris dans son évolution
dans sa transformation on est en cours
de route on n'a pas fini et rien n'est
parfait voilà il y aura des choses des
choses à refaire et mais en ce moment en
ce moment le problème sécurité interroge
interroge tout le monde comme ça se
passerait si si l'événement a été dans
été dans une autre dans une autre ville
je crois quand même sans
on rajoutait trop que le travail qui est
fait par le club de prévention parler
les centres socioculturels par les
espaces jeunes ou c'est fait de la
Réunion la première réunion suite au
décès de au décès à l'assassinat de de
Moussa et le travail des associations
enfin du sportif au point de vue
culturel je crois que ça a quand même
fait évoluer positivement et à la fois
l'intégration républicaine et puis la
vie la vie quotidienne dans la vie on a
quand même divisé par deux alors ça
c'est moi je dis ce que la police
m'envoie on a divisé par deux les taux
les taux de méfaits de délinquance il y
a eu toute cette rénovation
urbaine on pourrait y consacrer une
émission complète mais il y a un dossier
qui n'est pas encore terminé c'est celui
de la nationale 10 qui va permettre de
cicatriser véritablement cette commune
de trappes de relier une partie des
quartiers et puis le trappe plus ancien
avec l'Amérique cette nationale 10
est-ce qu'un jour ou l'autre elle va
être enfouie on annonce régulièrement
l'avancée du dossier mais pour l'instant
les travaux ne débutent toujours pas
alors où on en est
je garantis et c'est pas un
environnement par si tu me lecture de où
on en est donc maintenant les finances
sont inscrites
pratiquement complètement pour le projet
c'est à dire
et le plateau urbain on devrait
faire l'enquête publique nécessaire à
des travaux de ce genre là après les
vacances de 2015 au début 2016 et inédit
que que les travaux commenceraient mis
2016 début 2017 il y a 2 ans 2 ans et
demi de de travaux et de perturbations
mais après après la vie les changer
complètement quoi je dis ça avec fermeté
de ministères et de préfecture à ce
moment-là ça veut dire que tout le monde
sont difficiles on peut parler de
l'intercommunalité par exemple de 50 ans
en Yvelines qui réduit les d'un petit
peu les différents les différents
budgets est-ce que ça va avoir une
incidence sur le développement de
trappes et comment vous voyez un petit
peu la politique plus globalement qui
est menée d'économie aujourd'hui
alors le la première réponse oui il est
les décisions ne serait-ce que sur la
culture qui a donné lieu
la nouvelle majorité voilà
tout le monde est tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire il faut regarder et
puis économiser partout où on peut le
faire collectivement parce que nous
sommes plus dans une ville mais dans une
communauté d'agglomération communauté ça
veut dire quelque chose mais ça peut pas
être fait comme ça en mettant des gens
devant le fait accompli donc je
n'insiste pas je suis déjà déjà exprimé
là-dessus alors évidemment ben ça va
jouer sur toutes les communes mais ça va
jouer sur trappe nous on a on a en
dotation à peu près pour l'instant
100000 euros de moins que l'année
dernière bon ce n'est pas une
catastrophe mais il faut quand même
qu'on regarde comment comment on va
faire puisqu'on a voté notre budget
notre budget en décembre sur la
politique globale au niveau national
moi je tout le monde sait ce que je
pense je crois que il faut sortir de la
théorie pour aller aller vers la réalité
et je vais je vais citer un exemple il
est normal que il est normal que l'État
aide les entreprises moi je suis pas
contre ces entreprises j'ai toujours
travaillé dans des entreprises privées
donc je sais ce que c'est il faut avoir
des contrats il faut travailler et tout
il s'agit pas de parler il s'agit de
faire
l'état consacre à peu près 50 milliards
d'années aux entreprises sauf que il y
en a qui bougent il y en a qui bouge pas
et donc juste un exemple comme ça parce
qu'on peut on pourrait discuter des
heures et des heures
ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
pourquoi c'est pas contractuel pourquoi
donc je vous aide en tant qu'État pour
votre prospérité puis la prospérité du
pays mais on signe un contrat comme
comme nous on a fait avec même si la
même chose on a fait on a signé ce
contrat avec l'agence de rénovation
urbaine pour l'intégration de de gens en
insertion professionnelle sur les
chantiers que financer la rue on a quand
même fait
entrer à peu près 80 personnes donc plus
de la moitié sont encore au boulot quoi
voilà et donc c'était contractuel et
donc je pense même alors on peut parler
de beaucoup de choses mais je pense
qu'il faut avoir plutôt un esprit
rigoureux et pratique que que de
s'enfermer dans des théories financières
sur lequel j'entends beaucoup de
spécialistes me dire le mardi ceci et le
mercredi le contraire parce que il y a
un indice qui est apparu qui a changé
toute la révolution dans cette émission
nous donnons aussi la parole à la
principale liste d'oppositions au sein
du conseil municipal sur la commune de
Trappes aux dernières élections et c'est
la liste menée par l'UMP par la droite
Othman Nasro qui était tête de liste ils
sont donc arrivés en tête il a souhaité
vous interpeller une première question
sur Promopole
Promopole est une pépinière d'entreprise
qui est financée par de l'argent public
et par l'argent des entreprises qui sont
hébergées
elle a été dirigée pendant 13 ans par
Monsieur Gendron qui est meradjan au
développement économique de Trappes aux
côtés de Monsieur malin depuis 2001 donc
ma question est simple j'aimerais savoir
si Monsieur Malandain était au courant
des graves irrégularités de gestion qui
ont entaché la marche de Promopole y
compris sur le plan financier et sur le
plan du sous le son des malversations
dont on a parlé récemment est-ce qu'il
était au courant oui ou non de cette
gestion irrégulière de chronophage
dans votre réponse cette question de
Promopole oui donc je ne fais aucun
commentaire public surpromopole ce que
nous nous avons fait nous ne sommes pas
comment dire membre de chromopoles je
parle de la ville de Trappes je parle
pas des personnes ça m'intéresse pas
enfin
la ville de Trappes n'est pas membre de
promo Paul c'est la casquette qui est
actionnaire principale dit voilà et nous
nous avons passé avec homopold j'ai
besoin de quelques instants excusez-moi
nous avons
passé avec Promopole parce qu'ils ont
gagné un concours
une délégation de service public et pour
la ville de Trappes sur
le développement des entreprises Thorez
et mémoriser
c'est un dirigeant de la pépinière
d'entreprise ou même ça a été évoqué
brièvement par othmann Nasro qui sont
appelés devant le tribunal de commerce
de Nanterre aussi pour répondre des
différents déficits vous ne souhaitez
pas commenter il y a pas de commentaires
je ne me permettrai de faire un
commentaire qu'en fonction de la
décision du tribunal et pas en fonction
des accusateurs comme ça qui arrive et
la cravate les mains dans les poches et
qui s'imaginent tout savoir et on
manquera pas de venir vous voir à ce
moment-là pour vous faire réagir une
fois que les décisions ont été rendues
par la justice autour de ses affaires
c'est la fin de la dspérience
autre question la dernière posée par
Othman Dassault elle concerne votre
mandat
excusez-moi de prendre ça après pour
autant monsieur Malandin c'était engagé
pendant les élections municipales à
aller tout jusqu'au bout de son mandat
alors que les gavés une rumeur comme
quoi il allait passer la main
aujourd'hui on entend un nouveau s'être
rumeur avec un certain nombre d'élus de
sa majorité qui se comportent comme si
il allait y avoir une un passage de
relais à quelqu'un d'autre donc ma
question est très simple il s'y était
engagé a-t-il effectivement l'intention
d'aller jusqu'au bout de son mandat en
2020 comme il s'est engagé durant les
élections municipales est-ce que vous
serez maire jusqu'en 2020
mon inhumation mais autrement autrement
oui parce que ça a été évoqué votre
votre succession il y a eu l'arrivée par
exemple sur la commune de Benoît Hamon
ancien ministre député on a parlé de lui
éventuellement pour prendre la tête de
la commune municipal
été tout ça c'est c'est du bruit de
couloir ou de cage d'escalier etc ce
n'est pas du tout
pour l'instant je suis encore en
capacité physique sans doute en capacité
intellectuelle j'en sais rien si aux
autres de juger de continuer le passé la
main aussi
à un moment je vous en parlerai merci
à ceux qui a fait politiques et le
prochain invité pour le début du mois de
juin justement ce sera le député Benoît
Hamon qui sera à votre place à bientôt